-Thank you for coming
on our show.
I appreciate it.
I'm a big fan of yours.
-Thanks for having me, pal.
-Yeah, we're pals.
-Now we're pals.
There you go, bud.
I didn't do that. Sorry. I know.
I should have.
-Next time.
-Next time. We're pals.
Yeah, by the end. Yeah.
You are married to a
to a gentleman who is British.
And so you're living in London
and raising a baby in London?
-Yes, we do like half and half.
But we're in London right now.
-And how is that, raising
a kid in London?
-Well, it's like
he was born in London.
And then we left for a while
and now he's 19 months.
So his language
is kind of exploding.
-That's pretty cute.
A British accent baby.
-It's real cute.
-It is, right?
-Real cute.
-You're gonna
want to keep that accent.
-Well, we're coming back
to America,
and so he's going to lose it.
But, yes, he has a full
British accent.
-[ Brooklyn accent ]
Now he talks like this.
Hey, where's my milk?!
Where's my milk over here?!
The bottle's empty!
-Yes. Yes.
-[ Normal voice ] That sounds
just like your baby.
-I mean, that sounds --
You are just like my baby.
-I nailed it. Yeah.
-We got this.
-Are you homesick
for anything in America?
-I am homesick for -- And it's
also like -- It's all weird.
So, we speak the same
language, but, like,
the culture is so different,
you know, like,
even with the baby,
like, we eat like what?
When you're a baby here,
you eat Lucky Charms.
He eats Bovril.
Do you know what that is?
-Sounds delicious. Yeah.
[ English accent ] Would you
like a bowl of Bovril?
-A bowl would be bad.
-Hold on. I'm about to Bovril.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not far off.
-Okay. Is it like an oatmeal?
-I wish it was an oatmeal.
No, it's like
a beef gelatin spread.
-What are you talking about?
[ Audience groans ]
-It's so much worse
than what you think it is.
-Give that to the baby?
-Yeah, the baby loves it.
-Baby loves Bovril.
[ Brooklyn accent ] Hey, give me
more Bovril over here!
What are you talking about?
-It's foul.
-Really?
No, no, no Bovril.
-No. You put it on like toast.
It's like cow hooves
and eyeballs.
-Oh, stop it.
That is ridiculous.
-It is. It's like the stuff that
doesn't make it into a hot dog.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, that's saying a lot.
-Yeah.
-Because a lot of stuff
make it in there.
-They'll put anything
in a hot dog.
-They'll throw anything
Exactly. Yeah.
-And then when you're there,
it's like it's...
It's beautiful.
It's wonderful.
It's like a vibrant,
amazing city. I live in L.A.
the other half of the time,
which is, like, very different.
But when I'm in London,
I live in this
little cute neighborhood.
It's kind of like a village.
And you go to the fish guy
for your fish
and the corner store for your
paper towels and whatever.
-Cute. It's like "Beauty
and the Beast."
-It's pretty -- Yeah.
-You're Belle, you're Belle.
Every morning.
-Bonjour, hello.
-It does sort of feel like that.
-Yeah.
-I miss Target.
-Oh, they don't have Target?
-They don't have anything that
even remotely resembles Target.
You can't go to one store
for everything
in that whole country.
-There's nothing like Target.
-Oh.
-No, that's a game changer.
You go to Target, you go,
"Oh, my God."
-"Oh, my God. I didn't know
I needed all this stuff."
-I don't need the Bovril
anymore. Are you kidding me?
Let's go. I've got so many
choices at Target.
-I mean, you can't go
to one store for,
like, I don't know,
garden furniture and socks.
[ Laughter ]
You got to go to two stores.
-You got to go to --
No, not in Target.
-They got it all backwards
there.
-And you just get a cart of
stuff
you don't even really need.
-But you do.
-You didn't know you needed it.
-No. I'm gonna two-cart it.
I might two-cart this.
-Oh, you're a double-cart
Target guy?
-Sometimes. Yeah.
The clothes is great.
I love -- What is it?
Clothes, cat and something.
-I wish I knew.
-Does anyone know?
[ Audience shouts "Cat & Jack" ]
Cat & Jack.
-Cat & Jack.
-Cat & Jack is the best.
You get everything Cat & Jack.
For me.
-Right now.
-I've squeezed into it.
Yeah, like half shirts.
[ Laughter ]
Well, let's talk about
"Fatal Attraction."
Okay?
This is a big deal.
I mean, obviously, there's a new
adaptation based on the movie.
-Yes.
-You get the phone call.
"Hey, we're doing
'Fatal Attraction.'
We want you to play
the Glenn Close character."
Do you go, "Yeah,
I'm going to jump into this"?
-I go, "Why are you making
remaking 'Fatal Attraction?'"
Which I think is
what everybody probably says
when you hear about
any sort of reboot of any kind.
And then I read it
and I really liked what I read.
And then I spoke
to Alex Cunningham,
our showrunner, and what she was
trying to do with it,
which is I totally recognize
you don't want
to touch classic things,
but "Fatal Attraction" --
It feels very 1987
and I'm like the biggest fan
of the movie ever.
It's still delivers
like on every level,
except if you really boil it --
boil it down.
I didn't --
-Wow!
-I didn't mean to do that.
Lizzy Caplan, come on,
sucker punched us right there.
You Rickrolled us.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't see that one
coming at all.
-I didn't. I'll see ya.
-"If you really do boil it."
-Yeah. Yeah.
When you boil it down,
you realize it's a story
about a married guy
who has an affair
with the woman.
And in 1987 audience's minds,
it was like he makes
one little mistake
and we need to kill
that evil woman
who has the audacity for
sleeping with this perfect man.
She is the villain.
He is the hero.
There's no "wait a minute.
He was married
and she's clearly struggling
with some deep mental illness."
So, like, what is --
So our story --
Yes, it's a reimagining
of "Fatal Attraction,"
but for a modern audience
and it's set in modern time.
-You get to dive in
and actually really
play with the character.
-Eight full hours.
-Yeah, eight episodes. Good.
I'm loving this.
Also you were telling me
backstage you're getting a lot
of questions when you're doing
press for the show
about intimacy coordinator.
-Yes. This was not a job
that existed a few years ago.
Like COVID swabber.
It's like one of those. Like,
"Oh, that's your -- Okay."
-That job didn't exist.
-Yeah.
-Now I'm a professional
COVID swabber. Yeah.
-So it's "Fatal Attraction."
It's an erotic thriller.
It's not like
a thrilling thriller.
I mean, hopefully it's that too.
But, you know,
there's like sex scenes in it,
and now you have
this new person on set
who's an intimacy coordinator.
Now, myself and my costar
Josh Jackson, we've both been
doing that type of thing
a lot over the years.
Like, we're no strangers to --
He did a show called
"The Affair" for many years.
-Of course.
-I did a show called
"Masters of Sex" for many years.
Like, we done it.
It's not our first rodeo.
Like, we're old pros
at this kind of thing.
-We know how to do the sex.
-We know how to
[Speaks gibberish] but...
[ Laughter ]
-We know how to
[Speaks gibberish]
We know how to
-Yeah. So, back in the day when
you would do an intimate scene,
it was like you had a rough idea
of what it was.
It'll say in the script
like "they make love"
or "they make love on a bed
surrounded by candles."
Like, they might tell you
about things in the room,
but they don't tell you much
about like what you're doing.
And then the men,
if there's a man in the scene,
would tie up his,
like, you know, parts in
like a flesh-colored sock.
And the woman would put like
an adhesive patch on
and they'd be like,
"Good luck."
And then you just go for it.
-Yeah. Act.
-Yeah. You like scat
like a jazz musician.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not what you do at all.
-Well, those days are gone.
It was kind of a terrifying to
think about it like that now.
But now the way you do it
is the script
will be the same level of vague,
like "they make love"
and then an intimacy
coordinator will come in
and will write out
a very detailed e-mail,
like granular detail
of every single moment
of what that might look like.
And then you talk
about it a little bit,
and then you send that document
to your lawyers and your agents,
which, like, no matter
how old you are,
still feels like sending it
to your parents.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah. And then you approve it.
And then you go
and you shoot the scene.
I actually brought an example,
if you want,
from "Fatal Attraction,"
just to give you like a rough
idea of what I'm...
-Oh, yeah, set the scene.
-Our intimacy -- Yeah, yeah.
Just, like, get a little
erotic in your seats right now.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Alright. So the script says,
Alex, that's my character,
and Dan, that's Josh's
character, make love.
This is like a little snippet.
It was much longer.
-Yeah. Here we go.
-And no spoilers.
We changed a lot from this.
But just to give you
a little taste.
Both Josh and Lizzy
will be insinuating nudity
and given modesty wear
and padding for comfort
and desensitization.
[ Laughter ]
That was always weird to me
because [Laughs]
I didn't ever see the purpose
of the desensitization.
Like, you're not actually
supposed to be,
like, mashing your...
-Yeah. Stuff.
-Yeah, like there's
a certain level of respect
that you keep a safe distance.
-You hope. Absolutely.
-Desensitization.
When Lizzy is on top of him,
we will see her bare back
and partial topless nudity,
parentheses -- her
right side breast.
[ Laughter ]
What about her left breast?
-Yeah.
What if that's not
your good side?
-Well.
[ Laughter ]
We all have one better one.
Her left breast will be masked
by his arm positioning, covered.
When Dan is on top of Alex,
we will see his buttocks.
-Ooh.
-Just a good word.
-Buttocks.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Real sexy.
-[ Laughs ]
This is, like, the sexiest thing
I've ever read, right?
-Oh, my God. The steam is coming
off the page.
-I know.
And finally, the sheets
will cover most rear nudity,
but we may see partial buttock
on both Josh and Lizzy.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys.
-Paramount+.
-Get ready.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lizzy Caplan
in "Fatal Attraction."
Take a look at this.
-How has she never
brought you here before?
How can a person work
in the criminal courts building
and never come to Andolini's?
-I just moved here
last September, so...
Why? Because you had
to explain the cookies?
Maybe I just -- I like
having desserts described to me.
-September.
That's eight months.
That's 240-ish days.
I'm here minimum
three times a week.
Which means
that since you moved,
I have been here 90 times.
-Must be the place to be,
I guess.
-Or just the place
I always am.
-Lizzy Caplan, everybody!
"Fatal Attraction" premieres
this Sunday on Paramount+.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Lizzy Caplan!